BEEN TOLD TO DUCK DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
AFTER FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
CLAIMED CREDIT FOR OUR CURRENT
ECONOMIC BOOM YESTERDAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRED BACK
SAYING THE BOOM IS DUE TO ROLL
BACK OBAMA’S POLICIES BY CUTTING
REGULATIONS.
WHO IS RIGHT, WHO CARES?
THINK ABOUT IT, THE DEBATE WE
ARE HAVING ISN’T OVER HOW GREAT
THINGS ARE, THAT SHIP HAS
SAILED.
THE MEDIA DEMPSEY THERE IS NO
MORE DENYING THE
SUCCESS OF NOW IT ABOUT
QUIBBLING OVER CREDIT.
FINE, LET THE DEMS HAVE IT.
IT WON’T WIN THEM ELECTIONS BUT
IT MIGHT REDUCE THEIR TEARS.
AND MAYBE OBAMA HAD SOMETHING TO
DO WITH TODAY’S ECONOMY.
WITHOUT OBAMA WOULD WE HAVE
TRUMP CUSTOMER AT THE FACT IS,
THE DEBATE SAYS A LOT ABOUT LIFE
TODAY.
THE TRUMP ECONOMY IS SO GREAT
THAT TRUMP HATERS NOW WANT
CREDIT FOR IT.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW OBAMA WILL
CLAIM CREDIT FOR PUTTING KIDS IN
CAGES.
AND WHY NOT?
HE DID DO IT BEFORE TRUMP SO
IT’S CONFUSING.
IN THE DEMS WORLD OBAMA IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RESULTS,
ONLY THE SUCCESS FOR WHO EVER
CAME NEXT.
TECHNICALLY GEORGE BUSH WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OBAMA’S SUCCESS,
AND OF COURSE WITHOUT Ws DAD
WE WOULD HAVE NO BUBBA.
COULDN’T YOU DO THIS FOREVER?
WHO GETS CREDIT FOR
GEORGE WASHINGTON’S SUCCESS
CUSTOMER GEORGE THE THIRD OF
COURSE.
THEN THERE ARE THOSE WHO JUST
WANT THE ECONOMY TO TANK BECAUSE
THEIR HATRED FOR TRUMP OUTWEIGHS
THE LOVE FOR THE COME, COUNTRY
AND ALSO IMPEACHMENT FAILED.
SO WAR ERUPTS UNDER TRUMP, A
TWITTER WAR.
LIKE ALL THE WARS UNDER TRUMP.
NOT VIOLENT, JUST TRASH TALK AND
FINGER-POINTING.
I WILL TAKE THAT OVER THE OTHER
KIND OF WAR ANY DAY PIER JUST
REMEMBER IF IT HADN’T BEEN FOR
SMOKE SIGNALS THERE WOULD BE NO
TWITTER.
MAYBE LIZ WARREN CAN TAKE CREDIT
FOR THAT.
SPEAK OUT JESSE, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
IT DOES OBAMA HAVE A POINT ABOUT
CLAIMING CREDIT?
>> Jesse: I WOULD SAY THIS,
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU DAY A GIRL AND
YOU GUYS BREAK UP AND SHE GOES
ON TO MARRY SOME OTHER GUY?
YOU CAN’T TAKE CREDIT FOR THAT!
YOU CAN’T TAKE CREDIT FOR THAT
WHEN YOU BREAK UP WITH HER AND
SHE GETS MARRIED.
THAT IS NOT THE POINT.
THE POINT IS THIS, THE STIMULUS
WAS A PUNCH LINE DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
HE SAID SO HIMSELF.
HE WAS ACTUALLY JOKING, THOSE
SHOVEL-READY JOBS AREN’T SO
SHOVEL READY.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY, THEY
FIRST HAD THE ECONOMY WAS GOING
TO TANK UNDER TRUMP, THEN THEY
SAID IT WAS BARACK OBAMA’S
ECONOMY, THEN THEY SAID THERE
WAS GOING TO BE A RECESSION AND
THEN THEY SAID IT WAS ONLY
BENEFITING THE RICH AND NOW THEY
ARE BACK TO SAYING IT IS
BARACK OBAMA’S ECONOMY, IT
DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE BECAUSE
THEY CAN’T TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY BECAUSE THEY HAVEN’T
DONE ANYTHING TO HELP THE
ECONOMY.
IF THERE HAD BEEN A DEMOCRAT WHO
HAD TAKEN THE REINS IN 2016 YOU
WOULD’VE HAD STRANGLING
OBAMACARE REGULATIONS, A GREEN
NEW DEAL, PARIS CLIMATE DEAL,
WAR ON COAL, NO NEW TRADE DEALS,
TAX HIKES INSTEAD OF CUTS, NO
BONUSES.
IT WOULD’VE BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER.
THEY CAN’T NAME ONE SINGLE
METRIC THAT HAS GOTTEN WORSE
WHEN TRUMP CAME OVER AND TOOK
OVER THE OBAMA ECONOMY.
WAGES HAVE GONE UP, STOCK MARKET
HAS GONE UP, MANUFACTURING JOBS
UP, EVERY JOB HAS GONE UP.
THEY CAN’T HAVE A LITTLE
FINGERPRINT ON ANY OF THIS
SUCCESS IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE THAT AND THAT IS WHY THEY’RE
GIVING DONALD TRUMP CREDIT FOR
THE GOOD ECONOMY.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY’RE
OPTIMISTIC AND THEY SAY THEY’RE
BETTER OFF NOW THAN THEY WERE
THREE YEARS AGO AND THAT IS WHY
I BELIEVE HE’S GOING TO WIN
REELECTION.
>> Greg: I SAW YOU NODDING TO
EVERYTHING JESSE SAID.
I COULD TELL YOU WERE GOING,
YES!
>> Jesse: SHE WAS NODDING OFF.
>> Donna: AS YOU WELL KNOW I
TRY TO DEAL IN FACT AND NOT
MAKE-BELIEVE.
I DON’T TRY TO MAKE UP THINGS.
>> Jesse: YOU MEAN FAIRY TALE?
>> Donna: TRUMP INHERITED A
STRONG ECONOMY THE BARACK OBAMA
REALLY HELPED TO BUILD.
WE ALL KNOW THAT WHEN HE TOOK
OFFICE, PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA,
THE ECONOMY WAS IN A "HOLE.
"I WANTED TO USE A S WORD BUT
YOU
KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING.
>> Dana: A DEEP HOLE.
>> Donna: THANK YOU, DANA.
WE’VE GONE FROM 10% UNEMPLOYMENT
TO 4.7% WHEN BARACK OBAMA LEFT
OFFICE.
IT’S NOW AT 3.5%.
HOORAY.
11 CONSECUTIVE YEARS OF STRONG
GROWTH.
I AGREE WITH YOUR FIRST LINE, WE
SHOULD BE THANKFUL THAT WE HAVE
AN ECONOMY THAT IS WORKING, BUT
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE ARGUING FOR,
AND I DON’T KNOW IF YOU TALK TO
ANY DEMOCRATS AND I’M SO GLAD TO
BE SITTING NEXT TO YOU AT LEAST
ONCE OR TWICE A MONTH, IT BEATS
ANYTHING ELSE I DO DURING THE
WEEK, BUT WHAT WE ARE ALL
EXCITED ABOUT IS WE WANT AN
ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR EVERY
AMERICAN.
>> Jesse: DIDN’T WORK FOR
EVERY AMERICAN DURING OBAMA?
>> Donna: YES.
>> Jesse: IT WORKED FOR EVERY
AMERICAN UNDER OBAMA SO HOW DOES
THAT NOT WORK FOR EVERY AMERICAN
UNDER TRUMP WHEN THINGS ARE
BETTER?
>> Donna: THINGS GOT BETTER
UNDER BARACK OBAMA.
THE STOCK MARKET GOT BETTER,
WAGES STARTED GOING UP, THE
NUMBER OF UNINSURED AMERICANS
WENT OUT, THINGS GOT BETTER
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THE FACT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
INHERITED A 4.7 UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE.
REMEMBER, THE STOCK MARKET IS
ONE METRIC, BUT LOOK AT THE MOST
IMPORTANT METRIC, AND THAT HIS
WAGES.
WAGES BEGAN TO GO UP UNDER
BARACK OBAMA -- CRISPY FIVE BUT
NO,
IT JUMPS UNDER TRUMP EMILY’S
THOUGHTS.
>> Donna: ANYTHING UNIQUE,
HAVE GRAPHS AND MAPS, BUT THE
TRUTH IS I’M EXCITED THAT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE --
>> Jesse: I PULLED A
NANCY PELOSI.
YOU LIKED IT WHEN SHE DID IT.
>> Donna: IT YOU CAN SHRED IT,
IT DOESN’T MATTER.
BUT WHAT IS IMPORTANT --
THIS WILL HURT YOU.
>> Greg: OF GOT TO GO TO OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> Donna: YOU ARE REALLY
GIVING BAD FACTS.
>> Emily: THE POINT ABOUT
WAGES GOING, GROWING, IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION, WORKER WAGES
HAVE GROWN BEYOND MANAGERS WAGES
AND THAT IS SOMETHING YOU
POINTED OUT THAT ALL AMERICANS
SHOULD WANT TO FEEL.
WHAT IS SO INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS CONVERSATION WE’RE HAVING
RIGHT NOW IS DEMOCRATS ARE
SENDING SUCH MIXED MESSAGES.
JUST ON THE ECONOMY IS HORRIBLE
AND THE BENEFITS HAVE NOT BEEN
FELT BY EVERYONE BUT TO OTHERS,
IT WAS AMAZING BUT THIS WAS
STARTED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
THE REALITY IS ECONOMIC GROWTH
IS DRIVEN BY D REGULATIONS AND
TRADE REFORM AND ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND TAX CUTS.
THOSE ARE NOT THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STAND FOR AND
THOSE ARE NOT THINGS THAT
OCCURRED UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHAT IS CREATING THE WAGE
INCREASES A SUSTAINED JOB
CREATION AND THAT IS THE RESULT
OF THAT POSITIVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
AND WHAT I WILL SAY ALSO IS FOR
THE DEMOCRATS THAT ADVOCATE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE UNABLE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES, UNDER
THIS ADMINISTRATION, NOT ONLY
HAVE ASIAN-AMERICANS, BLACK
AMERICANS, HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
THEIR WAGES HAVE INCREASED AND
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES DECREASED AND
ALSO AMONG THOSE WITH ONLY
HIGH SCHOOL DEGREES.
I LOVE THAT UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION PEOPLE DON’T NEED
TO GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE THOSE
WITH JUST HIGH SCHOOL DEGREES,
THEIR WAGES ARE INCREASING.
>> Donna: PRESIDENT TRUMP, I
LIKE TO CALL PEOPLE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE HE IS MY PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: I WANT DANA TO GET IN
ON THIS.
>> Donna: HOLD ON,
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TAX CUTS WENT
INTO EFFECT ONE YEAR AFTER HE
TOOK OFFICE, THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE WENT DOWN FROM 4.7 TO 4.1.
ALL I’M SAYING IS WE CAN GIVE
BOTH PRESIDENTS CREDIT FOR A
STRONG ECONOMY, AND ECONOMY THAT
IS ONLY --
>> Greg: TEAR IT UP!
>> Donna: IT’S THE TRUTH.
>> Greg: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
TIMES WERE BACK?
WOULD OBAMA TAKE CREDIT FOR THAT
CUSTOMER COME GOING TO TWEAK HIM
IT’S BAD, I FEEL BAD, THIS IS
PARTLY MY FAULT.
>> Dana: HE WOULD SAY, IF YOU
HAD ONLY GIVEN ME A THIRD TERM
THEN THINGS WILL BE BETTER.
HISTORY HAS A VERY LONG SWEEP SO
I THINK THE TWEET
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID YESTERDAY
WAS SO ILL-ADVISED.
YOU SHOULD LET OTHER PEOPLE SAY
THAT FOR YOU BUT THE FACT THAT
HE TWEETED IT MEANS WE’RE
LEADING OUR SHOW WITH IT AND
HAVING A BIG DEBATE THAN I
PREFER THE DEMOCRATS DEBATE ON
STAGE IN NEVADA, AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT HISTORICAL DATA
POINTS, THAT ARE FACTS, EVERYONE
HAS STATED SOME GOOD FACTS BUT I
THINK IT’S VERY INTERESTING THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, EVERYONE WANTED TO
DO A CORPORATE TAX CUT AND OBAMA
WAS AT 27% AND THE REPUBLICANS
WERE AT 25% AND THEY COULD NOT
CUT A DEAL.
26%, LET’S DO IT, AND THEN THEY
WOULD’VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE A
LITTLE BIT MORE GROWTH BUT DON’T
FORGET IT WASN’T JUST THE TAX
CUTS, IT IS THE D REGULATIONS
THAT HAVE GIVEN PEOPLE A CHANCE
TO OPEN IT UP AND MAKE SURE YOU
CAN HIRE PEOPLE MORE AND PAY
THEM MORE.